today's morning rounds we look at the
potential health risks from pesticides
in our food nearly 70% of conventionally
grown produce sold in the US was found
to have pesticide residue according to a
new report from the Environmental
Working Group as we told you yesterday
strawberries spinach and kale topped
their so-called Dirty Dozen lists of
produce with the most pesticide
contamination the report was based on
USDA tests which have found that a
sample of conventionally grown kale
could contain up to 18 different
pesticides
Samantha Heller is a registered
dietician at NYU Langone health and
joins us with more on this good morning
good morning I said this in the makeup
room this morning my dad would literally
spend two minutes washing any produce in
the morning and I would always ask what
are you doing that for and he said don't
you see these people spraying with
pesticide wearing astronaut uniforms
[Laughter]
don't you see these people winning after
that I mean my question this morning is
was he onto something do we really need
to wash better oh I don't know if we
need to wash better but we do need to
wash and I think we forget when we buy
things like parsley or basil they need
to be washed when they're fresh
we need to wash melons and lemons and
limes and that doesn't take off just a
lot of the pesticide residue but a lot
of the other detritus that these these
vegetables and produce are exposed to in
transit and prep and stocking the
shelves so we do need to wash our fruits
and vegetables but a lot of us forget to
do your washing actually take it off
take the pesticides off it takes some of
the residue off but remember pesticides
also live in soil and in water so the
plan is sucking these up for nutrients
so it can be in the tissues of the plant
as well what we hear pesticides to meth
and it freaks a lot of people out how
worried should we be pesticides are
toxins and at high levels people that
are at risk are like farmers and the
sprayers you see in those like hazmat
Texas right and they can cause endocrine
problems like hormone problems the
neurological problems increased risk for
cancer so we do want to minimize our use
to pesticides we want to support local
farmers who are farming organically and
sustainably however when you're
consuming some of these some of the
produce that is on the Dirty Dozen list
that that we
and afford maybe to buy organically or
we don't have in our neighborhood the
benefits of how fantastic kale and
strawberries and spinach are for you
definitely outweigh the amount of
pesticide that has been found in them so
I don't want people to be paranoid that
they can't eat these so it's still
better to eat spinach than a
cheeseburger
yes we're talking about dead my parents
were in town this weekend and we made a
gumbo and we were shopping and I said
that I want all organics and he just
rolled his eyes at me
so it made me think if you can't always
buy organic or you all want to what are
the top three organics you should get
and the top three that you don't need to
have organic well if you're gonna go by
the Dirty Dozen list the top of the list
where the strawberries and the spinach
and the kale if I were pregnant if I had
little ones I might buy the organic baby
food I might you know for those nine
months focus more on the organic fruits
and vegetables that are in that Dirty
Dozen list but if I can't afford it and
if it's not in your area it's still
worth eating them you may just want to
eat less of them during those periods of
time fruits and vegetables are fantastic
for us and we are not eating enough of
them in this country so I don't want
people to get scared No why would I not
why would I want any kind of pesticides
in my body based on what you've just
said pesticides cause at Point well I
don't we don't ya live in an environment
where pesticides can stay in our soil in
our water for decades it's okay to eat
it as long as you don't eat a lot of it
well it's also we have to look at the
amount that's in the food how much is in
there and how much is going to actually
have an effect and increase our risk for
these these health issues that we
mentioned previously the EPA the USDA
they're saying the amount in these foods
are not enough to really cause a lot of
problems the Environmental Working Group
also says the benefits of eating these
do outweigh the risk of this pesticides
so what we can do is buy organic when we
can't afford it you can buy frozen when
the food's not in cease and save some
money doing doing that and right don't
use pesticides in your yard try not to
try not to use them in your home gardens
try to encourage your maybe local
supermarket manager to get local produce
that's organic or grown with fewer
pesticides okay tell the big
agricultural good advice thank you very
much